x é a minha proposta hoje é falar sobre
o título que eu dele é cinema na sala de
aula diálogos possíveis é eu não poderia
falar no evento sobre educação sem tocar
na questão da leitura né leitura no
sentido mais amplo a gente sabe que
quando falamos em texto texto não é só o
texto escrito na lei se o mundo ler se o
céu ler-se pegadas lence pegadas
deixadas na areia lêem-se imagens então
é na realidade a gente entende quando
falou a gente nem os profissionais da
educação principalmente aqueles que
atuam na minha área é que a área de
letras que a leitura é instrumento de é
a ferramenta de constituição de
cidadania ou seja não acredito que haja
um cidadão que possa exercer sua
cidadania na sua plenitude sem que ele
tem a ferramenta da leitura porque ele
está alijado do mundo na medida em que
ele não consegue ler esse mundo ou seja
há notícia de jornal uma imagem é um
próprio texto no sentido mais amplo para
ele não tem significado na medida em que
falta ele né uma formação como leitor no
sentido da formação do leitor
é o desafio que eu trago aqui é
justamente a imagem né
nós somos bombardeados por imagens todos
os dias a imagem faz parte do nosso
cotidiano já há um certo tempo não é de
hoje é um homem sempre teve uma relação
muito forte com a imagem
não precisa nem saber né sempre
desenhamos desde as cavernas
no entanto não é porque a imagem está no
nosso cotidiano que nós temos habilidade
para ler essas imagens isso é uma e
ingenuidade nossa parte então quando a
gente traz por exemplo o cinema para a
sala de aula é o cinema o filme né o
tipo do do subterfúgio que às vezes é
mal usado nas escolas professor faltou
você leva o aluno para a sala de
audiovisual passa um filminho porque
você tá pra aquele buraco
então hoje o cinema funciona mais ou
menos como funcionava a redação que é
outro mal que a gente faz também a
produção de texto faltou manda o aluno
fazer uma redação zinho aluno fez alguma
coisa errada manda fazer uma redação e a
gente está com isso tirando do aluno
prazer que ele possa ter em ver um filme
até escreveu um texto ora como qualquer
leitura necessário que você de
ferramentas para essa pessoa fazer a
leitura determinada coisa é a imagem é a
mesma coisa é você não pode levar uma
turma para um museu vamos levar tudo
para 10 que maravilha agora todo mundo
está indo a museus
levamos toda uma turma do 1º ano do
estado pra ver a exposição seja lá qual
for
se você não habilitar o seu aluno para
ele perceber o que se lê numa imagem é
claro que a visita é sempre produtiva
mas não será produtivo suficiente então
a minha proposta é que na realidade era
imaginamos uma metodologia é que eu
tenho feito desenvolvido na minha sala
de aula aqui na graduação é e tem
surtido efeito que os alunos é tem
comentado nem vão ver filmes e começam a
mostrar se chama de educação imagética
nem quer dizer o cinema está nosso
cotidiano todo mundo baixa filme vê mais
ver com olhos de ver né
mesmo quando se um filósofo francês diz
que o mundo tem um véu entre você o
mundo você tem que tirar esse velho
tirar esse véu como se tivesse véu à
parte novamente do conhecimento é da
pesquisa é do acesso ao mundo através da
da racionalidade então eu vou começar
aqui passando o peço desculpas para quem
já viu essa minha explicação é eu sei
que algumas pessoas aqui já viram é o
trailer na verdade nem trailer é a
introdução à abertura do filme tropa de
elite que até vai dialogar com uma série
de outras falas na que nós ouvimos aqui
na medida em que o filme fala de
assuntos na como drogas e traficantes
era então o que eu vou fazer aqui na
realidade não o que eu faço com os
alunos uma perspectiva dedutiva né ou
seja eu procuro que eles me tragam
obviamente lá aquilo que eles virão
porque a imagem algo muito íntimo do
aluno no entanto tem que construir com
ele o significado dessa imagem
então vou pedir que vocês passem favor a
abertura do tropa de elite
o meu brasil é um país tropical a terra
do pai que a terra do carnaval raso meu
rio de janeiro cartão postal
mas eu vou falar de um problema nacional
é nesse país todo mundo sabe falar que
favela f60 lugar ruim embora a 0 é o uso
de cada por toda sociedade mas existe
violence todo tanto da cidade de deus dj
ah ah ah ah minha cidade de mais de 600
favelas
quase todas dominadas por traficantes
armados até os dentes
simples né porque será que os créditos
com o nome dos atores está na cor
vermelha
e aí é claro que eles trazem o vermelho
lembra sangue vermelho a atenção ea
gente vai trabalhando os elementos que
compõem o filme por exemplo a montagem é
a montagem trilha sonora então essa
montagem é feita no ritmo do funk que
abre o filme se vocês perceberem né
a imagem é colocado papapa então aquela
vontade ela vai obedecendo a esse ritmo
do funk
outra coisa que a gente começa a falar
com os alunos também a gente procura é
claro ele sempre trazendo pra gente é a
questão do ritmo da fragmentação né
há uma série d e se essa abertura
funciona quase como um um pré filme né
casa você tem todos os elementos do
tropa de elite na abertura você tem o
símbolo do bope
você tem o baile funk você tem a ação e
ao mesmo tempo pequenos recortes
fragmentados né daquilo que vai ser
desenvolvido inclusive algumas cenas que
vão aparecer no filme enfim lá na frente
ora essa fragmentação ela é compatível
com o conteúdo do filme não tem como
diretor josé padilha fazer um filme em
2008 2009 numa sequência numa montagem
obedecendo a um ritmo que não é o ritmo
da contemporaneidade
então uma das questões uma das
qualidades desse filme é justamente é
atender
é por isso que ele fez tanto sucesso
claro são várias as razões mas é
justamente dar ao público é uma
realidade que ele conhece num ritmo
também compatível com aquela realidade
que está mostrando
eu poderia fazer um filme com outro
ritmo com uma câmera condição menos
nervosa e talvez não tivesse aceitação
não é outra questão que a gente trabalha
é a narrativa em primeira pessoa a gente
quando fala narrativa na solteira não só
o texto literário e cinema narrador sim
dois narradores no mínimo narrador no
cineminha câmera né
o que o diretor coloca no lugar que ele
quer porque quer dar determinado efeito
e permite contar a história determinado
ângulo então a gente tem uma certa
ilusão de que a linha que conta a
história que conta a história câmera e
essa câmara é o ouro do diretor no
entanto também há outras formas de
narrar né nesse filme especificamente a
uma narração em primeira pessoa feita
pelo personagem principal que é o
capitão nascimento essa narração foi
feita após filme ou seja uma versão do
filme que essa razão não aparece que
aquela que foi pra o para os camelôs não
é pirata
depois sentiu a necessidade de fazer
essa razão essa razão ela é fundamental
porque ela estabelece entre esse
personagem principal que é feito pelo
wagner moura eo telespectador
o vínculo é absolutamente necessário
para a argumentação que quer desenvolver
ou seja é quando ele chama o espectador
de parceiro né companheira minha cidade
companheiro parceiro vai ver só é mais
ou menos né a mesma técnica que fazia
machado de assis né quando chama leitora
o texto então você pode trazer por
exemplo autor como machado de assis que
as pessoas quando você fala machado as
pessoas têm a mesma sensação quando o
dentista diz pra você que você vai ter
um tratamento de canal né
e na realidade não é isso né machado não
tem nada a ver não dói é gostoso é
irônica e divertida e moderno
então você talvez fazer essa junção né
do narrador capitão nascimento o
narrador machado
você tem outras possibilidades de trazer
um texto considerado difícil né
um público com os nossos alunos de
graduação que talvez não tenham tido um
contato com machados outra forma
é na sequência quero passar o trailer do
cidade de deus outro filme brasileiro
procurei trabalhar pelos brasileiros na
obra é o filme premiado fernando
meirelles educação alunos direção é dele
e eu queria trabalhar para a questão da
fotografia então vou pedir que vocês por
favor passem o trailer
desde moleque
só que o destino e colocou aqui na
cidade de deus é abuso ocorreu do sul
pega se ficar o bicho pontos
naquele tempo eu pensava que os caras do
trio ternura eram os bandidos mais
perigosos do rio de janeiro que foi
também né meu coração escolheu morozova
mas alguém roubou o lugar dele na época
que ela ocorra
zé pequeno sempre quis ser o dono da
cidade de deus
já o benê só pensa em curtir a vida de
playboy da tarde lá na boca de cenoura
valeu de sua namorada já tinho vai cair
em formato mais acredito não está morto
aí pintou uma galinha de cidade de deus
virou notícia em sua casa é bom porque
eu o vejo na escola
calma nessa hora é o nome da banda
sonora aberto
o angélico estava louco para pedir
agilidade com ela de nova derrota
o furacão glória como vai ser dura
se você trouxer essas fotos de compra
bom esse é um dos trechos da cidade de
deus não sei se vocês sabem que existem
trilhas foram feitos vários trailers não
para cani um protocolo 1 para o brasil
então a gente tem uma tese a sua
dissertação de mestrado defendida na uff
e que o aluno vai analisar os treinos
diferentes feitos para públicos
diferentes aqui na sua na minha turma de
pós
eu trabalhei os cartazes né então a
gente pegou os vários cartazes é muito
interessante porque o cartaz americano é
a cena da alice braga com o buscapé na
praia
o cartaz francês já mostra o zé pequeno
nem ali passa com a arma é menino ainda
então a música e no brasil não no brasil
gera menos cidade de tauá já o título da
maior essa imagem é maior
as cores mudam né no do cartão americano
trabalha mas acordou trópicos mesmo
então essa é a praia é o amarelo é o sol
no cartaz francês não então é muito
interessante essa questão de um mesmo
produto mas ele é trabalhar de forma
diferente porque os públicos são
variados é claro é o que eu procurei
fazer com esse trailer é com os alunos é
obviamente trabalhar a questão como
disse que a fotografia poderia trabalhar
1 500 mil coisas que o filme é
riquíssimo e aí nós fomos vendo é e
depois de pisar nos dar um retorno é
como é que primeiro sentiu a ferramenta
pra ele ou seja existe alguém chamado
diretor de fotografia né esse diretor de
fotografia junto com o diretor vai
decidir na que cores é ele vai dar né
com aaa a gama de cor que ele vai
trabalhar como isso não é meu não é uma
tese é que existe é defendida na uff
também um aluno que vai nem o professor
vai analisar essa pessoa das cores é nas
três décadas que se passa o filme né
então você tem os anos 60 vocês viram aí
não ainda é um tempo mais idílico então
trabalha se com as cores mais quentes
têm o campo de futebol de terra batida
então a predominância saídos dos
terrosos né dos sons dos tons terrosos
na década de 70 quando a droga começa a
chegar na comunidade
o diretor de fotografia com césar
charlone estava tirando um pouco a cor
vai trabalhando com os tons frios neve
vai trabalhando com os azuis e cinzas e
na década de 80 quando o auge do tráfico
e vai tirando a cor você pode perceber
que é quase um filme preto e branco não
é a preto e branco mas é é a
predominância dos cinzas
basicamente outra questão interessante o
uso da câmera é a fragmentação mais uma
vez um filme moderno contemporâneo à
kaká como se não houvesse a
possibilidade de você dá conta daquela
daquela realidade então fernando
meirelles e corta a até às vezes e
divide em duas vidinha tem três ea
história contada nas duas partes da tela
ao mesmo tempo isso requer do espectador
é o filme que a gente diz né que que faz
com que o espectador realmente construir
um significado é o umberto eco tem uma
frase que eu gosto muito
o texto literário é uma máquina
preguiçosa que precisa do leitor para
que ela funcione
então tem certos filmes que não precisam
de nenhum leitor para fazê la funcionar
né filmes de entretenimento e fique
também são ótimos gente gosta muito
no entanto é filmes como esse exigem que
o espectador por exemplo vai ter que
escolher vai olhar mais para o lado do
calculado de lá que cê tem uma cena
matando a cedae está chegando a um lugar
e na outra metade da tela está se
mostrando que está acontecendo em outros
passa aquele mesmo tempo porque o tempo
é múltiplo quer dizer a chávez assunção
assim como o cinema tradicional mostra
família está aqui planeta ali na família
aqui e fui me instalar ao mesmo tempo
então isso gera no espectador uma certa
até angústia mas isso justamente o que o
diretor quer meu filho a realidade é
essa
vai lá ler como você puder né é a
questão da fotografia questão do
narrador mais uma vez não narrado em
primeira pessoa é estabelecendo esse
contato com o espectador e uma mudança
muito significativa é no sentido da do
personagem principal do livro acho que
sei que são livros paulo lins né é e que
o personagem narrador é um jornalista
e aí o fernando meirelles meta
linguisticamente
troca de jornalista para o fotógrafo
obviamente não é muito mais compatível
com o cinema ele é aquele que vai
fotografar cinema imagem
então tá feita aí a metalinguagem eu vou
fechar com psicose a famosa cena do
banheiro para trabalhar trilha sonora
essa esse filme de hitchcock né 1960 ele
teve uma um remake sobre o qual nem vou
falar pra mim eu nem considero esse e
mail tão ruim que é é o filme é de seis
pontos
embora o diretor de jornalismo alguns
lances mas enfim é o que a gente
trabalhou com esse filme né pessoalmente
agora na turma de pós mesmo é a questão
da trilha sonora a trilha sonora é a
gente explica por aluno que existem três
camadas sonoras no filme é a camada
sonora mais o óbvio que são diálogos os
sons e ruídos é a trilha sonora com a
trilha era na realidade uma terceira
chamada sonora dentro né do filme e aqui
o hitchcock pedro bernardi arrumava
fazer a trilha o rama fico pensando como
é que eu faço o que o instrumento que eu
vou usar optou pelo violino o violino
sincopado né você pode reparar que não
tem nada nem desses violino e isso é uma
metáfora fazer essa personagem ela
cometeu um crime roubou dinheiro do chef
enfim ela foge e tem toda uma idéia
dessa água nela está no carro chove ela
para nesse hotel no mesmo hotel
e essa água seja uma certa purificação
eu cortei um pouco a cena do banho é
porque eu tô aqui chegando ao seu final
mas tem toda essa purificação que é
quebrada com a chegada do do personagem
principal
e aí a gente mostra por aluno que há
três cortes nela é cortada pela faca né
é do anthony hopkins lá ela é cortada
pela transversalidade dos pingos da água
ela é cortada pela montagem do filme
porque o filme é fragmentado e ela é
cortada por esses acordes de violino
então são vários cortes agora isso não
só percebe essa riqueza e por que
hitchcock redes cópias martins copo
porque a gente fala dessas grandes
ninhadas grandes artistas na sua
assinatura tem toda uma construção de
uma imagem ou quanta coisa que não
aconteceu eu não passei nem um minuto
aqui de psicose isso numa cena de um
minuto você tem toda essa gama de
significados
então é isso que a gente quer que o
nosso aluno papo é perceber né a fazer a
multiplicidade e que atribua sentido
porque não adianta
nada você mostrar uma cena com tanta
informação se ele não tiver ferramentas
pra ler essas informações e então era
essa a minha é a idéia que eu queria
compartilhar com vocês hoje muito
obrigado